[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com we learned yesterday that the
FBI raided the house of donald trump's
former campaign manager Paul Manafort
ultimately campaign chairman after he
was replaced by Kellyanne Conway and who
else was it was the coca-cola kori
Wilbourn a young Paul man affords house
was rated the raid actually took place
late in July we just learned about it
yesterday though a search warrant was
presented and used to seize documents
and other materials and of course this
relates to the overall investigation
into possible collusion and illegal
activity related to Donald Trump's
campaign and Russia and according to the
New York Times the agents who showed up
at Paul Manafort house before dawn were
looking for tax documents and foreign
banking records Paul Manafort was not
given advance warning this is a serious
raid right this happens when you're
suspected of having evidence of crimes
and the FBI wants to prevent you from
scrambling to destroy that evidence
whether it's drugs financial records
whatever right if the FBI doesn't want
you scrambling and flushing evidence
down the toilet proverbially or
literally they show up very very late at
night early in the morning without
telling you in advance in advance
unannounced a no-knock warrant that
happens in this way and there's every
reason to believe it was a no-knock
warrant this is that there were no such
raids in Watergate we've heard that Paul
Manafort has been cooperating but
cooperating probably means his lawyer
has been meeting with investigators not
that he has been forthcoming and is
informing about what it is that went on
this is not good well I don't see what
the big deal is because former White
House press secretary Sean Spicer said
that mana fork played a very limited
role in the campaign for very limited
amount oh yeah yeah barely I mean he was
like an intern he didn't even really
have a phone
office he was just kind of in the
hallway filing papers he was only a
campaign manager for three months
including the time of the Republican
National Convention yeah where you
remember they took off that
pro-ukrainian anti-russian part of the
platform that's exactly right and the
silver lining if there is one in
learning that Paul Manafort received ADA
predawn FBI raid is that it's better
than it being Don junior right because
there's at least maybe the possibility
of creating a little more distance
between Trump and metaphor as Pat is
sort of joking about but it's pretty
transparent and this so this is news
right this is this is a major major
story but the real story for me is
actually related to this raid or I guess
you could say the timing of this raid
has revealed something very interesting
just hours after FBI agents raided Paul
manna Ford's home on July 26 Donald
Trump tweeted something very weird and
at the time it seemed like it was really
sort of out of nowhere at 9:48 a.m.
Eastern Time on July 26th again we now
know this was just hours after the raid
of Paul mana Ford's home Trump went on
Twitter and said why didn't attend ijen
Atal sessions replace acting FBI
director Andrew McCabe a Comey friend
who was in charge of Clinton
investigation but got big dollars
700,000 for his wife's political run
from Hillary Clinton and her
representatives drain the swamp so did
this timing happen because Trump did
know that the raid had taken place even
though it didn't go public until
yesterday and this was Trump expressing
frustration as a result of the decision
from the FBI to raid Paul manna Ford's
home now the the assertion made by Trump
in the tweet happens to be false no
surprise there NPR fact-checked it and
it is not true Governor Terry McAuliffe
pack donated to Andrew McCabe's wife and
McCabe was never in charge of the
Clinton investigation so it was all
bogus but needless to say the story is
the timing at the time it seemed weird
what you know Trump's mad about sessions
recusing himself on Russia
why is he today on July 26 going to
Twitter and slamming Jeff sessions and
talking about firing Andrew
babe now we know that the tweets were
posted just hours after the FBI raided
the home of Crump's former campaign
manager we don't know whether Trump knew
about it at the time but it certainly
puts a new layer into our possible
understanding of what happened that day
it's just like how Trump promised an
anti Hillary Clinton speech after the
Don Jr Russian lawyer meeting was
scheduled at Trump Tower but before it
actually happened where the basis of it
was dirt on Hillary Clinton right you
know I do think most people would have
the sense to just keep that under the
rug a little bit and not even bring it
up but I don't think he has that sense
not Donald Trump and I actually I'm
genuinely curious how many of trumps
seemingly out-of-place
or erratic tweets are actually related
to something that we haven't yet found
out about like might be the case with
this entire Paul manna for trade thing
and the real meaning right if we
interpret Trump's tweet about sessions
replacing Andrew McCabe what it really
means is can nobody get rid of this
meddling acting FBI director who keeps
getting closer and closer to finding out
the truth about the Trump Russia scandal
and by the way we were also wondering
about the timing of that transgender
band that Donald Trump announced on
Twitter without having planned the
announcement with quote his generals or
with the Pentagon or with Secretary of
Defense Jim mattis who was on vacation
at the time that was also on July 26 so
we again were just looking at the timing
was that meant to distract it would sort
of explain why he went to Twitter with
something that he hadn't even really
spoken to the Pentagon in his generals
and these distractions get even more
concerning when you talk about war with
North Korea had an idea being escalated
for someone who claims not to be guilty
of colluding with Russia he's sure
acting like someone who's guilty of
colluding with Russia and of course on
Fox News they're saying even if he's
guilty why do we care that wouldn't be a
crime anyway stunning timing the timing
always makes Trump look bad but it's all
going to be fine and good and there's no
story whatsoever if you listen to I
don't know two to five percent of our
audience I guess Donald Trump recently
made a major threat to North Korea
during an event held presumably between
rounds of golf at his Golf Club in New
Jersey
here is the threat that Donald Trump
made once again as a reminder in case
you may
that yesterday North Korea best not make
any more threats to the United States
they will be met with fire and fury
right like the world has never seen he
has been very threatening beyond a
normal state and as I said they will be
met with fire fury and frankly power the
likes of which this world has never seen
before thank you thank you so one
question was what kind of force would be
unprecedented since after all we've
dropped nuclear bombs on Japan twice
that was one question we had yesterday
after learning about Donald Trump's
statement another question about the
statement was is this an official
statement of the White House's position
on North Korea is it a formal threat who
was consulted about taking this line or
did Trump just sort of come up with this
for the moment and we've now learned
that this was totally improvised on the
spot by Donald Trump and there were
questions about whether he had a piece
of paper in front of him when he was you
know talking about this and there were
questions like maybe this was a prepared
statement about North Korea no yet
talked about with his generals or
whoever else might be and that was the
paper on the table in front of him that
paper apparently had opioid-related
talking points on it think about that
for a second it looks like Donald Trump
was delivering North Korean talking
points that the administration was on
board with and might have been on the
paper in front of him and the reality is
the paper had nothing to do with North
Korea this was just Donald Trump issuing
one of these erratic and escalating
threats completely off-the-cuff with no
seeming connection to the reality that
we're talking about tens or hundreds or
even hundreds of thousands or even
millions of people's lives here I
thought it was pretty obvious that it
was ad-libs though I mean one that's
sort of his style but also if you look
at his sentences there the second
sentence is pretty much a repeat of the
first maybe he may give the same words
he gets bullet he gets memos it's two to
three bullet points and a picture on one
page
maybe it's the same bullet point two or
three times right that would that could
have explained why he repeated the same
line twice seemingly not though
seemingly
we're talking about a dangerous
individual here right a total
megalomaniac loose cannon and it's yet
more evidence that what he said was not
planned or representative of the
American diplomatic position on North
Korea which we kind of had a sense of
because Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
immediately after Trump did this within
hours I believe it was he tried to calm
the situation down and sort of assured
American listen you can sleep at night
there's not an imminent war here and
this is where it gets even scarier
because of the haphazard nature of
Donald Trump's public comments
apparently just before this event
someone told Trump about a Washington
Post article that said hey North Korea
is making some progress miniaturizing
nuclear warheads so that we could put so
that they could put them on top of
ballistic missiles and Trump seemingly
was riled up because of that
and he issued this off-the-cuff threat
to North Korea this is a 71 year old man
who's president of the United States who
doesn't even have the self-control to
avoid reacting erratically because if
something someone whispers into his ear
before a camera shows up in front of
them I really wonder if he knew that
this threat would be heard around the
world and would be this top story
everywhere on the front of every
newspaper staff maybe though I think
youth was more prepared he certainly
would have his generals around him
because Miley and Conway and Tom Price
aren't the best type people I wish you
know when during this video as Trump
starts talking about unprecedented fire
and fury the camera zooms in and you can
no longer see the look on Melania
Trump's face nor on Kellyanne Conway's
face who is sitting I think on the other
side of Tom Perez as you indicated there
I would love to have seen the looks on
their face because that more than likely
they would have been completely
unreactive but that lack of reaction is
what would have been fascinating to see
in the video there reminded me of like
the subservience supporters in a rap
battle and he's the head honcho and
they're just sort of in the background
there to to sort of an idea for
emotional support and hype it up the
other possibility was we found out
recently how Trump gets a twice daily
propaganda file of positive things about
him like printed tweets and printed
screenshots from television
maybe he needed some new images of
himself on TV quote appearing strong for
his own propaganda briefing and thus he
thought hey here's an idea threaten
North Korea next time they put a camera
in front of me the biggest concern for
me is that you've got two erratic
megalomaniacs in Trump and Kim jong-un
and you've got a president who is almost
exclusively concerned with rescuing his
failing administration that has
accomplished nothing and this escalation
with North Korea is exactly what he
might see as accomplishing that goal
send me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at
a Pakman we'll take a break and be back
after this the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today be member of the day is
child interest charles thank you so much
for being a david pakman show member
this is independent viewer and listener
supported media and if you like the work
we do if you want to see it continue if
you want to see the program grow go to
david pakman.com slash membership sign
up for a membership we're talking about
a few bucks a month if you want a
discount you can get one using the
coupon code
I voted seventeen and we've also got a
major membership special I've been
promoting it as happening on Friday
August 12th for like two weeks and just
yesterday I realized there is no Friday
August 12th this year so candle it's a
major scandal it's Friday August 11th so
the the coupon code with a major
discount will be going out Friday August
11th and to be notified you need merely
to sign up for our newsletter at david
pakman.com I was checking out our reddit
discussion forum this morning at david
pakman.com slash read it lots of really
interesting conversations debates and
discussions happening there not the
least of which is a discussion about how
likely I believe the u.s. is to enter
into a nuclear conflict under Donald
Trump's watch and a lot of discussion
about that happening really just a lot
of concern about North Korea among the
nearly 4100 viewers and listeners that
are now subscribed to the reddit
discussion forum and understandably so
this is clearly a major issue right now
around the world I think the odds are
very low maybe they're only 5 percent
but the severity of that actually
happening is what's drawing so much
attention to it and why is it important
well in the next thread that I'll put up
on the screen for you there is another
one of our participants on reddit who
says there is a zero percent chance that
North Korea will attack the United
States first sort of arguing that
despite the bluster from North Korea
about Guam or we might build this or
send that that they are not so erratic
there that they would actually make a
first strike against the United States
and thus it's really a matter of his
Donald Trump going to take pre-emptive
action and I think that there
I don't think it's a 0% chance that
North Korea attacks the United States
first but I do believe that it is a very
low percentage chance unless Donald
Trump's rhetoric is just so out there
that it impacts Kim jong-un in a way
that we've not seen before and actually
causes him to take some kind of first
action against the US I could see them
flexing their military might in the
waters around Guam imagining them
attacking Guam preemptively I just don't
see it I don't see it either also from
our reddit discussion forum how to fix
poverty why not just give people money a
link to an interesting NPR article that
discusses among other things the impact
of a universal basic income something
I've talked about quite a bit I would
say basic income is one of the more
discussed issues on the reddit
discussion forum don't you think I would
think so we talk a lot about it on the
bonus show too it's a very tough thing
to market though it's really trying to
win conservatives over on the idea when
you talk about giving people money I'll
say especially people who don't deserve
it which is the main thing that the
right seems to be concerned with also
from our reddit discussion forum this is
really funny you should check this out
if the US had state TV in North Korea it
would look like this and basically what
has been done is there's link to YouTube
videos where you have the narration from
Fox News and other right-wing media
superimposed onto North Korean state
media where they make announcements like
for example that Kim jong-un was born on
the you know there was a double rainbow
the day we was born or he got 18 holes
in one during a round of golf or
whatever and it is a very very clever
thing and I encourage you to check it
out did you see these little videos no I
haven't but you know CNN anchor John
King tongue-in-cheek said that Fox News
with state-run media now in a sense it's
not unsympathetic to that idea they're
journalists don't push back and have you
seen Hannity Hannity now is fully just
the trumped propagandist at this point
also from our reddit discussion forum a
link to my video from a couple years ago
where I made Spanish tortilla in a
YouTube video and demands for not only a
pat live stream but also more cooking
videos and maybe someday I will cook
again I was thinking about a video
tutorial for how to make curried coffee
well that would be a very short video
be funny though I mentioned earlier last
week that I will be teaching at Boston
College starting in the fall I was
recently given a tour of like the
communication department sort of
headquarters and they've got massive
keurig present not massive Keurig
presence and I will not be partaking I
will put that on record right now in a
very strange turn of events Donald Trump
is now slamming Republican Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell on
Twitter
not that McConnell doesn't deserve a
good thumping here and there believe me
he does but to see Donald Trump attack
not only a Republican leader but one of
the Republicans who might depending on
where the Trump Russia investigation
goes actually could decide the fate of
Donald Trump's presidency sort of weird
Donald Trump took to Twitter and said
senator Mitch McConnell said I had
excessive expectations but I don't think
so after seven years of hearing repeal
and replace
why not done so what triggered this for
Trump Mitch McConnell recently said that
Donald Trump of course we Mitch
McConnell was asked in Kentucky at some
kind of constituent event
why hasn't more been achieved by the
Trump administration and Mitch McConnell
said something pretty reasonable which
is our new president has not been in
this line of work before I think he had
excessive expectations about how quickly
things happen in the democratic process
that's a pretty reasonable explanation
like Trump made all sorts of promises if
they were legitimate honest promises
it's very likely he underestimated the
difficulty of actually legislating in
the United States House and Senate it's
absolutely a reasonable and effective
attack you just don't expect it to come
from a fellow Republican I think that's
why this is a big story i I think that
Donald Trump is as I've said before a
sort of clueless buffoon with delusions
of grandeur suffering from megalomania
and that's why it's so weird to go and
attack someone that you need on your
side when he said something really quite
uncontroversial and the truth is Trump
is just as guilty of failing to aid in
the repeal of the Affordable Care Act as
Mitch McConnell they were all promising
impossible things sure Trump can sort of
hide under this idea that he's not a
career politician and he might not be
the most savvy at
knowing how this works but he's got the
ideas after all but he's just as guilty
of promising impossible things you know
for us on the Left it's nice because we
can sit back and watch this go down you
know we don't really have a stake in it
either way but I'd have to side with
Trump here because everyone in Congress
knew that Trump wasn't a policy wonk and
he wasn't going to be controlling
different members of Congress and trying
to get any sort of bill through that was
more the job of Congress I think
especially having talked about it for
seven years they've all failed I don't
think that there's a defensive Trump for
me here but they have all completely
failed and the other sort of odd thing
is I don't know if you've noticed this
Pat all of the breaks that Donald Trump
has taken from the 17-day golf vacation
that were in the middle of have been to
talk about things where his position
could be hugely damaging to endless
numbers of people in other words he took
a break from golf to threaten North
Korea with fire and fury like we've
never seen before
which presumably could lead to people
dying he came out to slam Mitch
McConnell for not repealing Obamacare
already which would have caused tens of
millions of people to end up without
health insurance and by most estimates
tens of thousands of people would have
died from lack of health care the big
picture is that this is a silly fight
for Trump to pick if there's another one
of these but if this ends up being
another off-the-cuff comment it's sort
of short-sighted if slamming McConnell
is part of some broader strategy I'd be
pretty curious to hear what that
strategy is but I do hope the infighting
continues because it's good for a few
reasons number one divided Republicans
will get less less less disastrous
legislation passed the Obamacare repeal
and replace is a good example of that
number two if you have more Republicans
not feeling loyalty to Trump they are
more likely to work with Democrats on
some more reasonable bits of legislation
and number three if Republicans are not
feeling particularly loyal to Trump
because he's slamming their leaders
those Republicans are less likely to
prevent or maybe they would even help
with the removal of Trump from office
depending on what the outcome is of the
Trump Russia investigation we'll just
take a look at what the Republican
agenda right now is are they going to go
after healthcare again probably not an
unreal endless defeats maybe tax reform
but I think you need 60 votes for that
which would be a lot harder for them to
do then you
getting the 51 to repeal the Affordable
Care Act so maybe Trump will go after
infrastructure next and that's something
that he can appeal to Democrats for yeah
although again he's he wants to do
infrastructure but in a way that's
basically crony capitalist handouts to
his buddies so yeah conceptually
Democrats might be more on board you
could isolate himself from the
Republicans that's true that that also
could happen so hey continue the
infighting Donny boy I love it if
there's anything positive that we can
say about Donald Trump's reign of terror
so far it's that the religious right
hasn't been as vocally and publicly
involved as they have been with some
other Republican administrations but we
might not be able to say that much
longer
lunatic Christian mega church pastor
Robert Jeffress is one of trumps
evangelical advisors and he has put out
a statement
brace yourselves get the kids out of the
room he has put out a statement saying
that Donald Trump has God's authority to
take out Kim jong-un the North Korean
leader he put out a statement just a
couple days ago where he said quote when
it comes to how we should deal with
evildoers the Bible in the book of
Romans is very clear God has endowed
rulers full power to use whatever means
necessary including war to stop evil in
the case of North Korea God has given
Trump authority to take out Kim jong-un
why do I feel like if the Donald Trump
Russia blackmail file P tapes exist
Robert Jeffress was the camera man in
the room this guy's a real piece of work
right truly bottom of the barrel and in
case you were wondering not only does
God approve of Trump taking out Kim
jong-un bold aboard and Gandalf have
also cleared Trump to go after him it's
also crazy to me to think about why
these people do this why these pastors
make these ridiculous claims because if
they turn out to be wrong does that mean
that God is fallible or that he's not
all-powerful or does it mean that their
credibility is just ruined these are
they don't actually have a direct
connection to Heiser totally
unfalsifiable statements like how could
it be wrong that God has cleared Trump
to go after kim jeong-hoon if Trump
doesn't go after him then hey God still
cleared him he just ended up not like it
these statements cannot be proven wrong
that's why they're so ridiculous I guess
it could just turn out to be a bad idea
which this obviously would be on its
face to begin with Robert Jeffress has
said in the past that former President
Barack Obama paved the way for the
Antichrist maybe that's true if he meant
Donald Trump but I don't know who
exactly he was thinking of where do I
agree with Robert Jeffress he did call
Mormonism a cult when Mitt Romney was
running in 2012 during the Republican
primary so I do agree with Robert
Jeffress at least about one thing even
if you consider geopolitics based on
religious texts valid I caution you that
a huge portion of evangelicals want
total Cataclysm and destruction because
they're waiting around for the rapture
or the apocalypse or whatever you call
it they believe that when it all gets
broken down they will end up in heaven
and all the sinners won't or whoever the
bad people are Jews well I don't even
know so violence and death isn't a
deterrent to them and that's why it's so
dangerous to pay attention to what these
sort of apocalyptic evangelical
Christians want especially when they
have a role in the White House now and
they talk about climate change what do
they even care if the rapture is going
to come in the next 20 years yeah it's
going to be great for them that it did
this is where they will live their life
out in eternity somewhere I don't even
really know by the way why is being an
evangelical pastor a credential to be
taken seriously on foreign policy
matters everyone should know you can
only take Southern Baptist series right
on foreign policy that's the only group
when it comes to religious texts that I
that I listen to I am kidding about that
because I don't no matter what I say you
could have picked Jews you could have
put too big the athletes doesn't matter
than any group yeah it just seems funny
or say Southern Baptists give a really
specific resources let's take a break
people discussing this we go on our
reddit discussion forum david pakman.com
slash
back after this the david pakman show at
david pakman.com welcome back to the
david pakman show we're continuing our
conversation today with Charles durbur
who's the public sociologist and also
author of the book welcome to the
revolution universalizing resistance for
social justice and democracy in perilous
times I'd love to talk a little bit to
sort of continue the conversation that
that we paused in part one about where
you see the actual next steps for the
Democratic Party and you alluded to this
a little bit at the end of part one of
the interview this idea of the
progressive movement working within the
Democratic Party and this is actually
something of quite a bit of both
controversy and significance because
we've seen a very centrist Democratic
Party what I call corporate Democrats
now make up a pretty significant portion
of the Democratic Party and yet on most
issues we've seen the United States move
to the left
whether it's abortion or health care or
LGBT rights or whatever the case may be
so what do you see is the most effective
way for progressives to have their
political desires heard and most
importantly made policy if that is
possible
well this is a really critical and very
contentious issue David on the left and
I'm not arguing that the left I think
the left needs to be in a constant dance
with the Democratic Party it can't put
all its eggs in the party but it can't
as it has often as many people already
can't ignore the Democratic Party in the
three historical periods where we've
seen universalizing parties of politics
on the progressive side which have
really made a difference the Gilded Age
the populist parties the New Deal and in
the 60s there was this dance I mean in
other words the movements
penetrated the party and you see now
with you know this came out very clearly
in 2016 race winning the conflict
between Hillary Clinton and Bernie
Sanders Sanders was kind of a voice of
the movement he saw himself that way you
know he called himself a quote
Democratic Socialist which was a major
contribution because you know after that
he first said that in a debate the most
googled word in America that day was
socialism would we need a conversation
about capitalism of socialism
that's not being heard in the mainstream
or in the mainstream parties
it's almost traitorous in in the
mainstream discourse to talk about
something wrong with capitalism as a
system or something good about
democratic socialism Sanders began to
pull the Democratic Party and the whole
country in a different direction this is
critically important we need this
conversation and the movements have
always they're always going to be
pushing from the outside to get the
party to move more in that direction but
the movement the party will never be
enough but to abandon it is to abandon
your ability to ever really get the kind
of policy and the kind of transformative
change that the movements are looking
for so I think Sanders is a really good
example after 2016 as you know there is
a legacy of Sanders supporters which is
you know the organization our revolution
it's got their chapters all over the
country working on the health care issue
working on economic justice and minimum
wage issues and so forth and you know
there's a there's a struggle going on in
the Democratic Party today which is
largely been obscured because there's so
much focus on the polarization that
Trump is created in the Republican Party
but that that was productive in moving
the Republican Party along during the
campaign and it's pretty good it's very
important for the Democrats now and so I
think that the movements have to play a
very strategic game in which there and
this is happening now which are running
for local office in town from Seattle to
Brooklyn all over the country you're
seeing these really movement based
progressive people penetrating into the
demo
partying running for office and so forth
but at the same time they're at what
movements always have to be there in
communities they're operating globally
online offline in the streets for much
more progressive transformative politics
than the democratic party maybe even
Bernie Sanders is prepared to do at this
point so my argument is that youyou
really strongly need to see a kind of
universalizing dance between the
movements on the streets and the
political parties I wanna give you one
one clear example of this in the United
Front idea in Germany when when fascism
came into power you had a lot of why Mr
Germany which was German at the German
Republic in the 20s it had very strong
gay feminists experimental cultural
movement that we would call identity
politics today
and it had some fairly strong liberal
and left politics the Social Democratic
Party that was running Germany and by
Maher for a while and a kind of insane
communist party that was very younger
DeAngelis of stone well
Hitler came into power because the
movements remained separate from the
social democratic and socialist parties
and remained fragmented from each other
and so you didn't get the United Front
whereas the far right which Hitler was
one of many far-right people began to
coordinate with the German aristocracy
at the time and create a united front
with corporate and aristocratic German
elites who had run German aid
you know before before the vive our
republic and and so it's just we're in a
period that a lot of people recognize is
authoritarian potentially moving in a
kind of neo-fascist direction and that's
where these universalizing united
resistance forces are very very
important and they failed in Germany and
I'm very
I've written a lot about fascism and
Germany and so I'm very conscious of
this and this idea of universalizing is
partly related to that concern that
unless we have these universalizing
movements that bring together
the movements and the political parties
and bring the movements together and
bring you know just coordinate because
you know at the heart of this is the
recognition that global capitalism is a
what academics like used to you know
like to call an intersectional system
that is there is a reflexive system of
you know dominant power hierarchies
which are interconnected race and
capitalism are not the same thing you
could have racism in other economic
systems in Elkin capitalism potentially
without racism both hard to imagine
America but they are really intertwined
like DNA DNA strands so in you're going
to change the system you need to
recognize and black feminists like well
whole bunch of them but people who
leading black lives matter now and so
forth call themselves socialists they're
you're seeing in a lot of these
movements in the environmental mum
you're seeing Bill McKibben who was very
insular and sidle and wasted a lot of
his work on on three fifty.org and a
Bartlett has moved much more to
understanding the connection I wrote a
book called greed to green earlier and
he blurb that book because he was
beginning to recognize that he couldn't
deal with climate change unless you deal
with capitalist and Charles I'm curious
and we have we have so much to get to we
actually are starting to sort of run out
of time even in the second part and I
had a dozen or so questions we were at
we got a really good answer to one but
there's a couple other things I do want
to touch on you're sort of talking about
the sort of positioning of what the Left
should have in American politics and
I've been pretty critical of Democrats
who have run basically on being
Republican light in many ways can you
address that a little bit and whether
it's time to really just be definitively
left absolutely I mean this started with
the Clinton years when the Reagan people
came in they changed they tried to
undermine remember from 50 years prior
to Reagan 8 1980 you had a new deal
I called regime a new deal of American
politics which operated under the system
of really an effort to move capitalism
as far as possible toward european-style
Scandinavian style you know justice
forward
kurz and bringing together all kinds of
social justice issues that element
Roosevelt Human Rights universal idea in
the rice and so but Reagan knocked that
out and then the Clintons came along and
explicitly said we're no longer the
Democratic Party is no longer a party of
the New Deal we're not for big
government were not for Social Welfare
and so forth and they did these very
incremental changes and move totally
toward an identity kind of politics
which was stripped of its class
sensibilities and awarenesses this has
gone on and and you know Obama
ironically in some way maintained this
he thought I think he felt he's a
cautious politician he symbolized you
know hope and change but he really
continued the Clinton strategy of kind
of moving away from these economic
justice system shaking kind of politics
toward a more I call it Bush and Bush
layer but two parties we don't have a
Labor Party we don't have a real
progressive party of United States like
there are in Europe so I feel yes to
your question this is a period and
that's why Sanders and you know people
like a little bit more and my senator so
far are so important because they
represent a new energy within the
progressive wing of the Democratic Party
a lot of them of the black caucus the
Progressive Caucus on the party you know
indivisible there's a whole set of new
grassroots younger millennial people who
are going to push the Democratic Party
to the left and this is the moment and
you mentioned David the public opinion
supports this you among Millennials more
Millennials say they are positive toward
the idea of democratic socialism I think
they're thinking about Sanders sort of
style rather and they're negative about
capitalism so if you look at public
opinion polls which I've put into the
book just to punctuate this point there
is enormous public support for these
progressive positions the Democrats can
win by highlighting these issues whether
whether it were they having to do with
you know medical care for all or social
security things which the Republicans
are going to be going after or whether
it's unions minimum wage the role of
money and politics you know citizens
united the public opinion is
there for the Democratic Party to really
move to the left but the Democratic
Party since Clinton has been funded by
Wall Street and by and the big
Democratic funders who play an enormous
role in where mainstream parties go have
been retarding that and they found
candidates in the Clintons and even in
Obama who were sort of reconciled
themselves to these traditional limits
of the Democrats since Clinton and this
is the moment for change for
transformative change and you know we're
in a period of emergency climate change
whether nuclear impossibilities in Iran
or Korea or whatever we don't have time
to play around and to be to be
incremental about this I mean
incrementalist at all kinds of change
are good but we need a mainstream party
that is going to shake this system up
and I think that's why Sanders who plays
you know is the most popular politician
in America of today according to Gallup
polls he's got a 60% approval rating in
red states as well as blue states so the
Democrats can have a 50-state strategy
and win all over the country as long as
they bring this kind of universal ice
cream message including to the trumpian
working class who is going to be very
disenchanted purely on economic grounds
with Trump's you know policies I mean
they might like his identity politics
that we talked about the beginning yeah
his he's really going to bring jobs that
are jobs that we've brought to plata
mall or whatever they may bring back a
few jobs but they're going there's going
to be no unions are going to be no
regulation no minimum wage and they're
going to be terrible jobs that most of
his followers are not going to be one of
doing a lot of what we've been talking
about from the book welcome to the
revolution universalizing resistance for
social justice and democracy in perilous
times we've been speaking with the
book's author Charles durbur thanks so
much for talking to us about the book
thank you so much David I'm really the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
we've talked about how Donald Trump is
very quickly damaged the reputation of
the US around the world in just this
first six months in office but this is
also a factor with world diplomats who
increasingly see our president is really
sort of a laughingstock a bunch of top
ranking European officials spoke to
BuzzFeed on the condition of anonymity
and they said that their chief concerns
with Trump are his unpredictable Twitter
usage as well as his generally erratic
behavior and they also describe the
president as quote something of a
laughingstock at these international
gatherings and that's so funny because
when we when we see Trump show up at the
g20 and other events and he acts like a
little kid in a really weird way the
diplomats and the other world leaders
are noticing which shouldn't really
surprise us and as one official
described it to BuzzFeed diplomats
considered Trump's vocabulary to be
limited to so few words and phrases that
they play a sort of word bingo when
Trump talks everything is great very
very great tremendous whatever can you
imagine
Trump goes up there and he says it's
going to be huge it's going to be big
league tremendous this I promise you and
then Angela Merkel from the back of the
room stands up and yells bingo
you have the bingo you have the
handshake game yeah you have posturing
for who's going to be in front and
center of the picture like a lot of
games of the morning montón agrees or
Montenegrin I'm not exactly sure what to
say Prime Minister I believe it was
shoved aside by Trump who popped up
there and a show that he is the guy who
gets to be at the front of the pictures
at the g20 the president's an
international joke and this matches
polling of European 79% of European
citizens have no confidence in Trump
according to a recent Pew Research study
and it seems European diplomats are sort
of in line with that exact same
sentiment one official added in speaking
to BuzzFeed he won't even want to listen
to the argument or have a debate he is
obsessed with Obama pretty astute
diplomats over in Europe they picked up
on Trump's vocabulary they picked up on
the fact that Trump just seems fixated
on criticizing Barack Obama and slamming
the things that Obama did and how he's
better than Obama but the saddest part
about all of us when I read about
is that the Trump fish don't care about
this they'll hear about this and they'll
say good I know I will get emails from
the handful of totally out there
trumpets who email me pretty regularly
they'll say David good for Donald Trump
the excuse me the fact that other
diplomats see him this way
it's because he's doing such great
things for Americans and that's who he
said he was going to help of course
European diplomats aren't going to like
him because he's so great for us I think
this is a big deal though because if you
remember back during the George W Bush
administration perhaps his biggest
failure was worsening the American image
and Europe and around the world and that
one called the Iraq war and because well
at heart because of the Iraq war Riya
and Obama's biggest success might have
been improving on that image and Trump
has toured that down in six seven months
in record time in record time sometimes
I do wonder whether Trump's bluster is
mostly when he's like at a friendly
rally or maybe on Twitter for example he
slammed Obama on Twitter endlessly in a
really vile and disrespectful manner
then he met with him after winning the
election and it's all yes mr. president
terrific meeting President Obama is a
good man he's got very very good ideas
goes to a rally ban Muslims until we
figure out what the hell is going on
blah blah blah then he goes to Saudi
Arabia he's holding hands with the royal
family yes sir mr. Prince never heard of
radical terror mr. Prince yep no sir yes
sir absolutely it there is some degree
to which Trump is like the he when he
has a medium of interference he is way
more aggressive than when we actually
has to show up and talk to people most
of whom are his intellectual superiors
right I think you know the lack of
support in Europe has to do with the
fact that they're a lot more left-wing
than we are here in America yeah and it
reminds me of that Economist poll that
looked at how different countries would
vote in the u.s. election for this
passed roundly driving and every country
listed there would have gone for Hillary
Clinton none of this is surprising right
like there's no outliers here that say
well you should really consider whether
Europe really thinks Trump is a joke
like every indication at every point is
suggested that oh and one more example
by the way of when Trump does like the
big man stuff on Twitter and at rallies
but then he
seems to get cooked even the entire
Mexico will pay for the wall stuff if
you look at that leaked transcript when
talk about Trump spoke to the Mexican
president Trump was worried that if the
Mexican president keeps talking about
how they're not going to pay for the
wall that it's going to be really bad
for the for the PR aspect for Trump he
seems completely unconcerned with the
actual immigration implications just
please mr. president please don't talk
publicly about how you're not going to
pay for the wall it's really really not
good for me
it's totally pathetic the guy Jay he
claims to be this great negotiator but
he gets out negotiated every time he
claims to be such an alpha male - there
was such a beta move I think it was not
totally bata totally beta a Walmart
store is being slammed after a picture
went viral of a back-to-school gun
display they had a big on the school
year like a hero display above a variety
of firearms as part of their August
back-to-school messaging Walmart has
since apologized they said they're
trying to figure out where did this
happen who put this up they responded by
saying that it was truly awful and
horrible and spokesman Charles Krause
and said to CNN money that the company
is not happy with this and they're
working diligently to find out where the
photo was taken and make sure that the
sign is removed Walmart had another
controversy recently when a Panama City
Florida Walmart
put up stacked boxes of coca-cola I
guess you could call them cases to
resemble the World Trade Center in some
kind of effort I guess to commemorate
9/11 back in September Walmart corporate
said we did not mean any disrespect and
they quickly took it down and then of
course back in 2014 Walmart had to
apologize for selling quote fat girl
costumes on its website who thought that
was a good idea and they've also had a
bunch of Nazi and racist memorabilia and
posters sold on their web sites before
but they said those were third party
products sort of like you can find
products on Amazon that aren't sold by
Amazon same sort of idea with Walmart's
website but it still doesn't look
particularly good I don't know if this
is the biggest of deals though because
yes we can go after Walmart for selling
guns or maybe being too large of a
corporation but we all know that
mistakes are going to happen in retail
every now and then and sometimes there's
a bit of irony involved or I guess
it's insensitivity in this case but as
long as they apologize for the
negligence is it really that big of a
deal well I don't go to Walmart I
haven't been there in more than a decade
but having worked in retail before I've
told stories about my exploits at the
now-defunct circuit city to me this is
pretty clearly the doing of a particular
employee usually the way they were
deliberate uh what's that you think this
was deliberately done well it was
deliberately done by some employee now
whether they did it to create
controversy or because they thought that
the guns were part of the back-to-school
specials I don't know but and most of
these retailers corporate send to the
stores these packages with signs and
these diagrams that are usually very
difficult to read and explain sort of
like where do you put each thing and
management gets them they usually just
give them to somebody who's making who
knows how many few dollars per hour and
they say yeah put this display together
so I I think it's pretty clear that this
is no corporate policy of Walmart to
market guns is back to school it's
either a joke from an individual
employee or just a mistake from an
innocent employee if it's a mistake
that's one thing I don't think it's that
big of a deal if there was some intent
behind it and that employee went rogue
and thought this would be funny that's a
whole nother deal I would be hard to
prove hard to prove intent for sure you
know who's furious though about this
this apology Education Secretary Betsy
DeVos how were schools going to protect
themselves from grizzly bears if Walmart
doesn't offer back to school school gun
discounts or even just potential
Grizzlies they write the butch is really
the only actual concern if Walmart
really wants to apologize there's a lot
that Walmart should be apologizing for
right Walmart should apologize for
claiming to be this great
self-sufficient business and the beacon
of capitalism and bootstrapping and
whatever when they actually depend on
government welfare programs to subsidize
the low salaries they pay their
employees everything from food stamps to
Medicaid while right-wingers point to
Walmart as this free market big business
success and it's not just Walmart that
that criticism is valid for we've talked
about it with McDonald's all these
companies that talk about their amazing
business acumen and how they don't
depend on everyone they built this great
business they've built those businesses
on the Commons with employee benefits
heavily subsidized by government welfare
and we've seen Walmart had these
end-of-the-year
donation rally yeah or benefits for
their own employee right
I mean how bizarre is that maybe they're
offered free guns as well I doubt it I
doubt that but that would be that would
be interesting do you shop at Walmart
ever i-i've know lately sweating off
Walmart years ago and I know that for a
while there there were sort of rumblings
but target is just as bad as Walmart for
that type of store I've done enough
research where I'm generally confident
saying target is not as bad as Walmart
if you're going to be going to one of
those stores and I get it sometimes it's
you know 9:30 at night
and you need X immediately and it's
either Walmart or Target and while you
might want to go to some local business
you're not able to
I do believe target is better than
Walmart especially if you live in a
rural area in the middle of the country
and Walmart is the reason for a lot of
those local businesses yeah cutting down
to begin with you know what I've been
hearing about I know that some people
that I sound so out of touch when I say
this but it's very different in cities
than it is in some parts of the country
I've heard that in some parts of the
country the the one grocery store is
walmart walmart has grocery items I
don't know if in all stores or just some
stores at this point I think it's just
some I know they have pantry items in
most stores but as far as the karcher
delivery yeah and people are going to to
Walmart for groceries and Target also
has I was recently at the Target in
Hadley Massachusetts and you can get
fruit there you can get I don't know
what else I don't know yeah so anyway
sad I find I don't know why I find it
depressing like you can say hey
Walmart's one of the biggest purveyors
of organic foods in the country by
volume that's probably true but I still
find it depressing and I don't know
exactly why you don't got to do it
someone's got to do it I guess and
that's who is pushing out a lot of small
businesses in more rural parts of the
country we have a voicemail number two
one nine two David P Troy York is not
happy with me because of my comments
about Donald Trump being a draft dodger
here is what Troy York had to say hi
this is Troy York listening to your
comments about Donald Trump his bone
spurs and not serving in the military
let me ask you David Pakman and your
girlfriend rules and you serve in the
Argentine military
will you defend Argentina even the
whelen invaded or how about Israel did
you serve in the Israeli army which many
young folks are required for two years
service move to deal with the
Palestinian dog that they must reside
with come on until they further conquer
territory in the Middle East I don't
think you serve me military mr. Damon
angry so why are you on Donald Trump's
past Oh for not Saudi military and my
yanqui why should he serve in the
military oh look it end up like a man
like John McCain right well a lot of
offensive stuff in this voicemail but
the what number one no I didn't serve in
the Argentinian army because I was five
when I left Argentina and usually you
don't put five-year-olds in the army
most countries don't I don't know how
they do it in every country but most
countries don't have five-year-olds in
the army and I didn't serve in the
Israeli army because that was never a
resident or citizen of Israel and Troy
York seems fixated on me either going
back to Argentina or Israel a country I
didn't I didn't live there to begin with
and now that I serve in the militaries
of these countries why would I it
doesn't make any sense well it was Trump
criticizing Blumenthal's military
history when he himself dodged the draft
and insert right what is it out they do
anything out that hypocrisy is
irrelevant very weird but always great
to hear from Troy York or Cecil Brewster
or Luis Jimenez or whatever his Latino
persona is that he'd come up with over
the years we've got a great bonus show
for you today don't miss it david
pakman.com slash membership it's
tremendous we will love it that folks i
can guarantee
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
you